صلاح يكتب تاريخ ليفربول والايام ستنصفه
بهذه الكلمات تعبر جيمي اسطوره نادي
ليفربول الانجليزي والمحلله التلفزيونيه
الحالي عن رايه في النجم المصري محمد صلاح
اعتبر صلاح واحد من اعظم خمسه لاعبين في
التاريخ النادي الاحمر العريق ليفربول
بالتاكيد مشيرا الى ان الجميع سيعرف ذلك
عندما يتوقف الهداف الحالي عن اللعب بقميص
النادي الاحمر محمد صلاح طبعا مشاهدينا
كان قد سجل هدفه رقم 186 بقميص النادي
الشمالي العريق ليصبح خامس هداف في تاريخ
النادي بالتساوي مع ستيفن جرارد وذلك خلال
300 ومئات 302 من المباريات بينما حقق
الاخير ذات الرقم خلال 710 مباريات مو
صلاح
محمد صلاح سجل يوم السبت الماضي هدف رقم
30 في كافه البطولات مع ليفربول خلال
الموسم الحالي واحرز هدفا على الاقل في
اخر تسع مباريات ليفربول على ملعب انفيلد
في انجاز تاريخي غير مسبوق
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات